Planning: Negotiation is a process, not a single meeting.
Write down your objectives,...
...needs; what you must get,...
...wants; can be conceded if you get something in return,...
...would be nice; bargaining chips. Try to anticipate the other side's desires.
Five Steps to Negotiation.
One. Engage in small talk and build trust.
Two. Share and listen carefully to objectives. Be interested in a win-win outcome.
Three. Conflict is natural and shouldn't be avoided.
Work on the "needs" first, then "wants", finally resolve unimportant issues.
Four. Expect change and adapt. Look for creative solutions.
Be open to compromise. Always work for win-win.
Five. After agreeing, write down the details of the agreement.
Develop skills to...
...diagnose conflict.
Be effective in initiating confrontation.
Listen to the other's point of view.
Use problem solving to bring about a consensus.
Remember:
Try to please both parties by putting yourself in the other's shoes.
Be willing to "own" part of the problem.
Talking about your feelings is more effective than acting them out.
Establish common goals and stay focused on them.
Work for satisfactory solutions if the issues are important to you.
When discussion ends, summarize decisions and develop next steps.